عندما تقول إن جمهورية
إيران الإسلامية تحترم حقوق الإنسان ، تقول إحدى
المتظاهرات
إنها احتُجزت داخل
منشأة للحرس الثوري لأكثر
من شهر واغتُصبت من قبل ثلاثة
رجال مختلفين ، ذهبت إلى
رجل دين بعد ذلك لأنها كانت
تفكر في الانتحار.  كانت مستاءة للغاية
تحدثت معها سي إن إن إلى رجل الدين هذا ،
فهل من المقبول أن يتم القبض على
المرأة واغتصابها مهما فعلت ،
وهناك العديد من التقارير حول
الاعتداء الجنسي في هذا الوضع ضد
النساء والرجال
أولاً في المظاهرات السلمية
في الخريف.  لم يتم القبض على أي شخص ، لذا
فأنت تنكر أنه
في تلك الاحتجاجات التي
أصبحت عنيفة ، تم اعتقال بعض الأفراد
الذين دخلوا إيران من الخارج
وكانوا يستخدمون الأسلحة النارية ويقتلون
الشرطة ،
فأنت تعلم أن المرشد الأعلى
أصدر بالفعل مذكرة
تم الإفراج عن كل من تم العفو عنه وجميع من تم سجنهم
باستثناء أولئك الذين قتلوا
شخصًا ما أو تمت مقاضاتهم
بشأن النساء الإيرانيات اللواتي
ذكرتهن ولا أستطيع أن أؤكد أنه
كان هناك الكثير من هذه المزاعم التي لا أساس لها
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وفي وسائل الإعلام.
هذه ليست بلا أساس
ولم تكن على الإنترنت ، لقد
تحدثت سي إن إن إلى رجل دين وشخص متدين
داخل بلدك وحصلنا على هذا وقد
رأينا بعض تقارير سي إن إن
المستهدفة والكاذبة ، وهذا ليس صحيحًا
نحن نبلغ الحقائق ونبلغ
الحقيقة وهذا هو سبب جلوسك
معي السيد وزير الخارجية ، هل يمكننا المضي
قدمًا؟
أريد أن أسألك أن يكون لديك زوجة ،
ربما لديك أخوات ، هل لديك بنات ،
أريد أن أعرف ما هو رأيك في
الاحتجاجات السلمية من أجل التغيير في  الطريقة التي
تستطيع بها النساء عيش حياتهن في
إيران الفعل السلمي المتمثل في إزالة
الوشاح ماذا يقولون للنساء في
عائلتك ماذا يقولون لك
أولاً وقبل كل شيء أود أن أقول إنه في
إيران لدينا أقوى ديمقراطية
خاصة  مقارنة بالعديد من الدول الأخرى ،
هناك معايير وقواعد وأنظمة
في كل بلد
والنساء لهن دور مهم في إيران وقد
اكتسبن هذا الدور بعد انتصار
الثورة الإسلامية في إيران
اليوم الشبكات الخارجية التي
يقلبن قضية الحجاب و  الحجاب
في أزمة سياسية
المرأة في إيران ، ثم إطار
القواعد واللوائح تتمتع
بحريات غير عادية ، انظر إلى الشيء الذي
أعرفه نوعًا ما عن هذا ، لذا فأنا أعلم أيضًا
أنه في بداية الثورة
لم يكن هناك تفويض بالحجاب لأولئك الذين
أرادوا ارتداء  الحجاب في مخطط أو
يمكن لأولئك الذين لم يكن لديهم من لم
يكن لديه سوى عدة أشهر أو ربما
بعد عام من قول آية الله لا ، كل ما عليك
أن ترتديه أيتها النساء ، لذلك
أحاول مرة أخرى معرفة
ما  وما الذي ستفعله الحكومة
لأنه حتى
آية الله هارموني قال مؤخرًا إن
النساء اللواتي لا يرتدين الحجاب ليسن غير
متدينات ولا ينتهكن
الدين ، وقد قال بعض الأشخاص الآخرين
أننا سمعنا من رئيس
البرلمان السابق السيد لوري جوني  من
قال في البداية هل نحتاج حقًا إلى
إحداث كل هذه الفوضى حول الحجاب ،
لذلك أريد أن أعرف معك تقبله
لأنه أيضًا النساء
المسنات التقليديات اللائي خرجن إلى الشوارع ،
إنه رجال ، إنه شاب ، إنه
مختلف تمامًا عن  الاحتجاجات السابقة ، هل
تقبل أن النساء
يمكن أن
يكون لهن مظاهرات سلمية من أجل التغيير
ومن أجل حقوقهن الخاصة ، هل لديهن
الحقوق التي تقول إنها
الديمقراطية الأكثر تطورًا ، هل للمرأة
الحق في سلام
في مثل هذه القضايا ، فإن
نهجها هو أسلوب الكيل بمكيالين ،
دعني  أطرح عليك سؤالاً لكنني في الواقع
أقتبس من نفسك
لحظة واحدة فقط لا أريد الدخول في
مناقشة. أطرح عليك سؤالاً
أريد أن أطرح عليك سؤالاً قبل
الإجابة على سؤالك ، لنرى من أين
بدأ كل هذا بشخص إيراني  فتاة تدعى
ماسا اميني توفيت لانها
مجرد
لحظة رجاء
فتاة صغيرة ناسا وافتها المنية اميني
حولوها الى رمز من اجل
تغيير النظام في ايران باسم
الدفاع عن حرية المرأة سؤالي هو
هذا
الزميل.  لك
وكصحفية ، إنها سيدة
مسيحية وفي وضح النهار
استشهدت على يد النظام الإسرائيلي الذي
دافع عنها يا سيدي وزير الخارجية ، لقد
دافع عنها الجميع ،
وأدان الجميع موتها ،
وماذا كانت نتيجة ذلك.  لم
أذهب إلى عالم دولي لماذا لم
يسمحوا بإثارة القضية ، لقد
أدان موتها السيد وزير الخارجية ،
أنا حرفيًا أسألك عما إذا
كنت تعتقد في إيران أن للمرأة الحق في
الاحتجاج السلمي وبالمناسبة كما
تعلم  أفضل مما أفعله أحيانًا
تكون شرطة الأخلاق عدوانية
وأحيانًا تقول السلطات
فقط خذ الأمور بسهولة ، وماذا
نرى
منذ هذه الرئاسة لقد رأينا
حملة قمع على النساء وملابسهن
وحقوقهن لماذا لماذا يفعل أي نظام لماذا؟
هل يحتاج أي نظام لإثبات نفسه على
خلفية حقوق المرأة في
مساحته الجسدية ، فلماذا يبدو أن طلبي
عليك أن
تقابلني ولكنك في الواقع
تواجهني في مواجهة هذا هو
السؤال الأخير الذي أطرحه  بحاجة إلى المضي قدمًا ،
أحاول الحصول على إجابة
وهذه ليست الطريقة لإجراء مقابلة ،
أريد فقط أن تتمتع
النساء في إيران بجميع
الحريات اللازمة في إطار
القانون ،
هل تسأل الدول الأخرى من  موجودون
في منطقتنا لكنهم حلفاء
للولايات المتحدة ، نفس
الأسئلة التي تطرحونها عليّ حول
حجاب المرأة ، القضية في إيران في
الوقت الحالي ليست قضية الحجاب ما
علاقة الحجاب بإرهابيي منظمة مجاهدي خلق.
ما هذا الحجاب الذي
يرتدينه وهم مقيمون في أوروبا والولايات المتحدة
وهذه المرأة التي
أرادت أن تأتي وتصبح رئيسة في
إيران لماذا أقامت
الحجاب الإجباري في
منظمتها الإرهابية وهم أصدقاء
للولايات المتحدة؟  إنهم أصدقاء
البيت الأبيض ، فلماذا يجب أن يكون هناك
معيار مزدوج حسنًا ، لذلك أدرك أننا
ربما وصلنا إلى نهاية هذا
الجزء الصغير لأنك لن تجيب
بعد الآن
ولكن كما تعلم ،
رد فعل حكومتك العنيف  لقد أدى رد الفعل ضد المرأة إلى
تغيير السياسة الخارجية
وعلاقاتك مع العديد من البلدان في
العالم ، تم فرض المزيد من العقوبات
ضدك ، ولم يعد الاتفاق النووي الإيراني بأكمله
على استعداد للتفاوض
حتى لو كنت على استعداد لأنهم لم يعودوا
مستعدين بعد الآن للولايات المتحدة وأوروبا.
لكن أولاً ، أود أن أسألك عن
شيء آخر مهم حقًا وهو
الأسلحة الإيرانية الموجهة لروسيا والتي
تستهدف الأوكرانيين خلال هذه الحرب ، هل
يمكنك أن تخبرني لماذا تتبع سياسة إيران
إرسال طائرات بدون طيار وغيرها من أشكال
الدعم العسكري إلى الرئيس بوتين التي اعتادت
على  قتل المدنيين داخل أوكرانيا لماذا
ترسل طائرات بدون طيار لانتهاك جميع
أنواع العقوبات ولكنك لا تزال
تتسبب أيضًا في حدوث قدر كبير من الموت
قبل ذلك ، أود أن أقول إن
النساء في إيران يشكلن
جزءًا مهمًا جدًا من مجتمعنا.  لقد
تحولت إلى
قوة ديناميكية وفعالة للغاية ولن نسمح
باستخدام امرأة إيرانية نشطة تلتزم بقيمها من قبل البعض الآخر حتى
تتبع معاييرهم وتحت
ذريعة الحجاب يخلق أعمال
شغب وإرهاب اليوم.
مكانة خاصة جدًا ليس فقط في
إيران ولكن في جميع أنحاء العالم
أينما كانوا في العالم ، فهم من
بين النخبة ، لذلك يجب ألا
نحاول التقليل من هذه المكانة المهمة
التي يتمتعون بها فيما يتعلق
بأوكرانيا ، فنحن نعارض الحرب في أوكرانيا
ونحن  لم نرسل أسلحة إلى أي من الجانبين
ومنذ بداية الحرب
حاولنا إيقاف الحرب حتى
يركز الطرفان على حوار سياسي
وهذه هي نفس السياسة التي اعتمدناها
في حالة اليمن وأفغانستان ودول
أخرى مختلفة في  أزمة
بشأن الاتهامات التي
وجهت ضد إيران فيما يتعلق بالطائرات بدون طيار ،
فهي غير صحيحة ، لقد كان لدينا
تعاون دفاعي مع روسيا في الماضي
ونستمر في هذا التعاون ، لذلك
لم نوفر لروسيا أي أسلحة
لاستخدامها في الحرب في أوكرانيا.  لذلك ربما تكون قد
شاهدت هذه الصور
بشكل صحيح ، فهذه طائرة بدون طيار ، وهي
طائرة بدون طيار إيرانية تم العثور عليها في الداخل وتم
استعادتها من أوكرانيا ، وكذلك مع
رئيس أوكرانيا الذي يقف
بجانبها ، وقد قارنوا ذلك بإيران ،
هذا هو الأوكراني ، هذا هو
الأوكرانيون وهذا من مصادر مفتوحة
من مثل اليمن ، كيف يمكنهم إثبات هذه
الطائرة بدون طيار من خلال صورة فقط ، هل
تنكر
أن هذين الأمرين نفس الشيء الذي
دعني أشرح لك ذلك ، فأنا حتى لا
أشرح لك حسنًا ، لكن هذا ما
الأوكرانيون يقولون وتلك
صور نفس الطائرة بدون طيار التي
تعرضونها جميعًا في المعارض أه العسكرية والمعارض
والتي تم اكتشافها في اليمن
وغيرها حيث تكون نشطًا سأشرح
لك ما حدث
قبل بضعة أشهر اتصلت بالأوكراني
أنا ووزير الخارجية قلنا ما هي
هذه الاتهامات التي لا أساس لها من الصحة التي
وجهتموها بشأن إيران وقال إن لدينا
بالفعل وثائق تفيد بأن
روسيا تستخدم طائرات شهيد الإيرانية بدون طيار
في أوكرانيا وقلت له انظروا نحن
جاهزون لفريقكم العسكري
والفريق العسكري الإيراني.  للجلوس
والنظر في هذه الوثائق ثم إصدار
الأحكام ورتبنا لعقد
مثل هذا الاجتماع
في عمان
وجلست الفرق العسكرية الأوكرانية والإيرانية
وكانوا يعرضون لنا بعض
صور الأقمار الصناعية الغامضة للغاية وكانوا
يزعمون أنها إيرانية  طائرات بدون طيار
ولكن ما أظهرته لكم لم يكن مجرد
خبرائنا الذين قاموا بفحص هذه الصور ولم
يكن للصور أي صلة بإيران على الإطلاق
ولمدة أربعة أشهر كنا
ننتظر الجولة الثانية من
المحادثات ونتوقع منهم أن يأتوا
ويقدموا وثائق أكثر وضوحًا ولكن
يواصل الفريق الأوكراني القول في غضون أسبوعين
قريبًا ، لكن لم يحدث شيء ، لذا
قلت إن
الحكومة الإيرانية قالت إنك أرسلت
طائرات بدون طيار روسية من طراز شهيد ، لكنك قلت قبل
الغزو ،
لكن يبدو أنه وفقًا
لدبلوماسيين غربيين ، لقد أرسلتم الكثير بعد
تم إطلاق المئات من الطائرات بدون طيار الإيرانية
وضرب أكثر من مائة منها
وفقًا للأوكرانيين
أهدافهم ، فهي أهداف مدنية
داخل أوكرانيا ، ولهذا السبب
تعرض روسيا مبادلة مقاتلات ميج ،
وهذا هو آخر الأخبار للطائرات بدون طيار
وأشياء أخرى دبلوماسي غربي آخر
تقول نعم ، إن سؤالك طويل جدًا ، وأعلم
أنه طويل جدًا ، لكنني أحاول أن أقول
الحقائق لأنك تقول إنه لا
يحدث ، لذا أحتاج إلى إجابتك ، ولهذا
السبب هناك عقوبات مرة أخرى ،
سألنا نظرائنا الروس
وقالوا إننا لم نستخدم اللغة الإيرانية
صنعنا طائرات بدون طيار في أوكرانيا
وقلنا لنظرائهم الأوكرانيين إذا كان
لديك أي دليل موثق أظهره
لنا سننظر فيه ولكن
الجانب الأوكراني لم يظهر لنا أي
دليل قوي لإثبات هذا الادعاء
باستثناء بعض اتهامات وسائل الإعلام
وأنا.  يمكن أن أقول لك
صراحة كوزير خارجية
جمهورية إيران الإسلامية أننا
ضد الحرب ، نحن ضد الحرب في
أوكرانيا ضد الحرب في أفغانستان
ضد الحرب في اليمن ضد الحرب في
فلسطين ،
وقد بذل رئيسنا جهودًا كبيرة
من أجل وقف الحرب  في أوكرانيا
قبل بضعة أشهر ، طلب السيد ماكرون من
رئيس بلدنا أن يأتي ويتوسط
لأنه يتمتع بعلاقات جيدة مع
روسيا ،
ثم أرسلني الرئيس السيد الرحيسي
إلى موسكو وتحدثت مع المسؤولين الروس
ونحن نواصل جهودنا التي
نعتقد أنها حرب.  ليس حلاً
لا في أوكرانيا ولا في أي مكان آخر في
العالم